être acteur c'est savoir choisir ses
rôles et savoir choisir ses réalisateurs
et pour ça il faut beaucoup de
personnalité mais cette personnalité il
faut savoir l'oublier parce qu'après il
faut rentrer dans le rôle
et puis il faut obéir aux réalisateurs
et peu de gens savent faire ça on
invitait d'aujourd'hui a fait près de
100 films avec parmi les plus grands
réalisateurs tout en restant lui même
tout en étant différent
voici le grand michel piccoli
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur le plateau
explique à la une merci alors nous
allons parler tout à l'heure de votre
prochain film qui sort au moins d'août
oui mais pour le moment je voudrais je
viens de dire que vous aviez fait près
de 100 films oui peut-être même
peut-être manipule faut pas compter dans
ces cas là si vous me disiez celui qui
est le plus cher à votre coeur
il y en a beaucoup en fait je dirais
presque tous on dirait mais alors il
bouffe à tous les râteliers il ne sait
pas il faut faire un choix dans la vie
je n'ai aucun regret tous m'ont appris
quelque chose c'est qu'elle est celui
qui a coûté le plus cher à écouter le
plus cher c'était un film de lelouch pas
ou peut-être le film que j'ai tourné
avec costa gavras je ne sais pas quel
est celui qui à votre avis est le plus
éternel de tous pour l'instant je dirais
peut-être pour l'instant oui éternelle
et sa voix pour l'instant c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être le mépris de
godard
parce que godard a commenté est
quelqu'un de très important
on dit que c'est un fou dangereux
sinistre épouvantable mais on s'aperçoit
qu'un film comme le mépris et est déjà
un classique et le plus nul je ne
citerai pas
très bien mais plus confortable le plus
le tournage le plus calme le plus cool
je ne connais pas beaucoup
le plus porno c'est lequel le plus pour
nous d'une certaine manière c'était
peut-être un film que j'ai fait enfin
c'était pas pour nous des guenons
c'était pour nous dans la tête donc
érotique
c'était un film de ruffec un berlanga
metteur en scène espagnol qui ses
grandeurs gâcher en grandeur nature oui
et je vais comme quick lane est une
poupée gonflable extraordinaire et très
bien là c'était oui c'était mystique la
grande bouffe dans votre livre dans
votre vie que sorti à dix ans chez orban
qui s'appelait au dialogue égoïste oui
un truc qui est très vexant à la fin
c'est que bon lit tout le bouquin c'est
pas mal d'ailleurs
et puis à la fin il ya omission égoïste
vous refuser de parler de juliette gréco
bon ça encore on peut comprendre vous
refuser de parler de vos chats bon ça on
est pas trop on n'est pas trop triste
par contre ce qui est bizarre c'est que
vous refusez de parler d'eux par exemple
de d'elizabeth taylor vous avez une
histoire cachée avec elizabeth taylor au
pop
qu'entendez vous par là non absolument
pas non et non et là vous avez bien
connu
non je l' ai connu tout à fait par
hasard ne se souviendra pas j'étais un
petit acteur inconnu et son imprésario
de l'époque étaient venus voir une pièce
de théâtre dans laquelle je jouais m'a
dit oh mais vous êtes très bien ou de
les faire du cinéma en amérique
venez dons
j'ai maxime
j'ai quelques amis là je voulais vous
parler vous connaître un peu mieux et je
suis allé dîner chez maxim et bêtement
je sais pas ce qui m'a pris six sont
tous très gentils ces étrangers ils sont
très célèbres y avait dix à bethel
heures il y avait chez plus qui est
bêtement ça m'arrive souvent
heureusement d'ailleurs
j'ai dit oh c'est pour moi l'addition
très bien alors j'ai eu tort d'abord
parce que j'avais pas l'argent rapproche
et deuxièmement parce que ce monsieur
est mineur américain mais vous et vous
êtes fous de payer vous même nous on ne
paie jamais société très bien pu faire
une autre question qui me brûle les
lèvres c'est que quand vous étiez chez
sabatier cet hiver là au jeu de la
vérité
on vous a parlé de rika zaraï en vous a
dit est ce que vous vous soigner par les
plantes
et puis vous avez dit oh bah oui les
plans de toute façon tout le monde sait
que ça soigne que ce soit la camomille
ou le haschich et vous soigner plus
souvent la camomille ou à chicago may et
camargo la très bien merci beaucoup
michel piccoli
[Musique]